while the San Francisco 49ers had a
major hole in the middle of their
defensive line when they traded to force
Buckner to the Indianapolis Colts for
the 13th pick in the draft after trading
down one spot from 13 to 14 with the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers the 49ers took
defensive tackle Javon Kinlaw filling
the spot at the 4th Buckner opens up and
look this is what you have to do if
you're going to manage the salary cap
over the long haul in San Francisco
you've paid Dee Ford you've paid our
Armstead you're eventually gonna have to
make Nick bow so one of the highest-paid
players in the NFL on the defensive side
of the ball if not the highest paid
defensive player so now you've got
Kinlaw for the next five years
any reasonable salary this is smart this
is what you have to do you have to let
some guys go or stunned to see Buckner
leave the 49ers but if Kinlaw comes in
and plays well they'll quickly forget
about Buckner and then at some point
it'll be somebody else who has given the
farewell as the 49ers continue to try to
hold a great team together so 49ers move
Buckner get Kinloch spend a lot less
money and haven't taken a receiver yet
but they don't need to rush to take a
receiver there's so many in this draft
they can sit tight at number 31 and take
the best guy there or even wait until
later as they trade down like they did
from number 13 and amass more picks and
those rounds that they had opened up
with past Ray's rounds 2 3 & 4 we'll see
what the 49ers do over the course of the
rest of the evening
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports